[Music]
all right so good afternoon everyone
I'm Nicholas the tech lead for hundreds
to design tools and the constraint
layered library and that's what we're
being we are going to talk about today
so you might have noticed we released a
really cool navigation editor we are not
going to talk about that today but there
was a session this morning it's on
YouTube check it out there is code labs
it's really cool so we are going to talk
about the layout editor the work we've
been working on the entire team this
past year the improvements we made
specifically will focus on sample data
which is something really cool we
shipped in 3.2 and we'll also talk about
constantly at 2.2 and what's coming up
with this libraries for first for the
section under layout editor by the
manticore going to present you thank you
hi everyone so to start with we're going
to talk about delay it a little most of
you are probably quite familiar with the
tool so it's a graphical tool that
enable you to build your layout without
having to write any xml and it's
supposed to make you more productive so
what is nice with the layer data in that
it also works with your custom views so
if in your code you have a custom view
it will render in the layout editor and
the nice thing is that any custom view
from your project will appear in the
palette so our goal is really to make
you more productive so we've added some
nice features this year to do so
the first one I want to talk about is
the conversion so if you right-click on
a view you will see the convert view
option that will make this pop-up appear
and you will be able to select one of
the preset component or you can use the
edit text just to pick any view from
your project and this view is contextual
so if you right-click on a view which is
not of your group we will show some
preset of non view group views the next
thing I want to talk about is a
navigation between include layout and
their parent so in the component tree or
in the preview if you double click on a
component on an include tracker it will
jump automatically to the children and
if you click on the arrow on the top of
the component tree it will jump back to
the parent this is quite handy to go
fast between two layouts the layout
editor is really powerful you'll twist
constrain layout and constraint layered
is a great a great layout because it's
very powerful but it's very verbose
right so you might not want to write all
your XML by hand so what you should do
instead is take advantage of all the
menus we have in the layout editor to
generate this XML for you so again
right-click on the view and then you can
use the align any of the top option to
choose your option and we have many of
them so feel free to check them after
this session and really it can make you
more productive but most of you are
probably populating your layout at
runtime you have data from the internet
and you want to populate them so they
are not rendering at the layer in the
layout editor so to solve this issue
Jigga gonna come here and talk about the
sample data so before we talk about
sample data let's talk a little bit
about tools attributes so the tools
attributes are the XML attributes now
you actually use to give additional
information to the to the under studio
under the layout editor you are probably
familiar with many of them
we are not going to talk about all of
them let's covered one example just to
be clear on this so you probably have
seen this so in your strings file you
get a lint warning saying that you
haven't translated a particular string
usually what you want to do is to fix
this error you translate it and that's
it the error is gone but there might be
valid reasons what you don't want to
translate actually this is string it
could be that is the name of the
application and you don't want to
translate it in every single language or
in certain languages so what you can do
here is you basically can tell hundreds
to do look I know about the server but I
don't want you I don't want you to tell
me about it because it's fine so that is
one example there are many others but
what we want to talk about now is
actually design time attributes this is
just a subset of the tools attributes
that I talked about
there are given additional information
and context to the layout editor so
let's see it with one example so in this
case what we have is we created our
toolbar we edited the layout on its own
so we use constraint layout we created
it and this is how it will look in the
layout editor so what you can see is the
toolbar without any context so you can
see the layout but you don't know how
it's going to look at runtime in your
application so there is something that
we can do you can again tell the layout
editor this layout is going to be
included in this other layer that I'm
hinting here so using this attribute
choose show in we are letting the layout
return know that we want to embed this
header into the main layout and that way
we can see it in context so now when we
are editing we know if the colors match
we can actually tweak our design and see
how every change impacts our layout and
the best thing is again you can do it
you can edit it right there you don't
have to see it with a blank space or
anything like that
so let's see another interesting use of
design-time attributes when you add a
textview this is
usually what you get so you have hello
world and that's it but you can tell to
the layout editor that you know that
this textview is going to look a
slightly different at runtime and you do
that but again using the tools namespace
so in this case what we are doing is we
are replacing both the text and the text
color and we are telling the layout
editor at runtime this is going to look
different and we are about to see how
this is very useful let's go with a
slightly more complicated example when
you add a recycler view this is what you
get by default it takes the space you
can see how the recycler view is going
to be laid out but it's not very useful
it doesn't help you to actually come up
with a good design for it
it's just a list of elements with a lot
of empty space so again we can use the
tools attributes do you basically let
the layout editor know this is the
layout that I'm going to use so you have
probably seen already list item many
times very simple you just say but we
can do other things we can tell the
layout editor okay how is this going to
look with five elements all these things
you usually cannot do them in the layout
editor because these are things that
happen at runtime so usually the source
of information for a recycler view is an
adapter so the adapter might depend on
network on database on many things that
we don't have available at the same time
so doing this you give us context and
then the layer tool will render
correctly similar to what you have at
runtime so let's now go into sample data
so sample data is it's a feature that we
introduced in 3.0 and what it does is it
helps you to actually populate data that
is not available at the same time so in
this case what we are doing is telling
the layout editor that I want to use the
tint property and I want to get the data
from this data source which we call at
sample as less material colors and that
data source is simply a file a plain
file with a list of colors that you see
there so what happens in the a design
time is the layout editor will get a
different color for every item so
that looks better wait but we can do
more so let's see how you create that
that file you go to your project new
sample data directory and that is how we
create at the directory what we are
going to put every data source that we
have in our case we want to create
material colors so new file and then we
name it material underskirt underscore
colors and we just put the list of
colors and that's it is that simple now
you can use it in any property in this
case tint so this is one of the types of
data sources that you can use in sample
data so it's basically a list of colors
you can have lists of any kind that you
want like regular text and you just
replace it in your text field but you
can have other things more interesting
that you can have dimensions so if you
have dimensions using the tools
attributes you can tell the layout
editor I want to use this dimension and
I want it to be different for every item
and you can do that using sample data we
also have other types of data sources
you can have images you created in a
very similar way what you do is you
create instead of a file you create a
directory and then you drop all your
images in there and then recyclerview
will get a different image for every
item so it's very simple and the last
type that I want to tell you about these
JSON files so JSON files is a similar
way to the list that we had before but
it allows you to do something that you
cannot do with this is you can have all
your data together in one place you can
add maybe context about why a particular
item is like that or you can even get a
sample from your dead API and put it
into the sample data in this case what
we have is a list of nodes so what you
can see is we have a title and we have
an alpha and the way that you use this
in sample data is you can reference any
of those live elements let's see how to
do that so in this case what we are
telling the layout editor is
I want you to replace text at the same
time and I want you to do it with
example as last the name of the JSON
file and then the note that we saw
before so in this case we are doing it
with title and also remember that this
will change depending on the name of the
JSON file it doesn't even need to be
called JSON but if you don't want to
provide your own data sources hundreds
to do will also provide it or it already
comes with a a set of predefined ones so
you don't have to create your own we
give you a set of them we give you names
we give you a lot and ipsum obviously
and we also give you a set of images for
example you can use avatars and you
don't even need to create images you can
just use the ones that we give you and
again how to use that is very similar
the only difference that you can see
here is we added tools as the name a
space of the data source so instead of
being at sampled now is a tool sample so
using syntax completion you can see like
all the different data sources that we
have now but in three two we added new
features in order to help you to use
this so everything that we saw was
already available in three oh and in
three two we are adding a few things
that Vadim is going to tell you about to
help you using sample beta sample data
is a great tool but we love tools and so
we decided to put a UI on top of it so
what does it look like I'm sure most of
you already did that so you have an
image view you're taking it from the
pallet and the resource picker will pop
up and since you just started your
project you have only the launcher icon
available so you is it and you preview
doesn't look really great so what you
can do it's 10 now in the resource
picker you have the sample data category
and you can pick any resource data from
your project or the predefined one so
now our image view looks better and we
can see every instant of it in our
recycler view but what if you want to
make some change to this sample data
what if I just want to use one single
email from myself
so we've introduced in Android studio
3.2 is a new design time helper that you
can access by clicking the wrench icon
right below the image view so here I'm
gonna uncheck Juliet and this will give
me the ability to select only one image
from my set and I cannot try it out with
any image from this set but no let's say
that we want to give it another look and
we want to pick images from another data
set so we can just use the drop-down
button and select another data set and
here we go our respective you as a brand
new look so it's very nice to preview
what it would look like with different
kind of images so you can always jump
back to the resource picker and have the
full set of resources available back he
keeps a Browse button on the bottom of
the pop-up and the same option are
available and also want to mention that
if you select a sample laid out on the
resource picker it will populate the
design-time attributes so it won't it
would be remove at one time we have the
same design time design time helper for
textview so here for example I'm just
selecting a different set for each view
for each textview and as you can see on
the recyclerview
each item is taking one instance of each
own set for each each item right and
finally we've also added this feature
for recycler view and this is quite nice
you can browse between all the templates
we provide for you and the file will be
automatically created so you can just
jump back to the credit file and preview
your changes and all the design-time
attributes are automatically populated
so you don't have to do anything to
preview it and take full advantage of
sample data but the data editor is even
more powerful if you use it with
constrained layout so Nicola is going to
come on stage and do a deep dive into
constraint layout
we release constantly arts officially
from the stable version last year we
announced it a couple of years ago so if
you don't know about it it's a library
that allows you to easily create user
interfaces and we try to encourage you
to use flat hierarchies which is coming
very handy for animations its support
level it's compatible essentially
everywhere it's small and you're in full
control and when you ship with a
specific version or not it comes with a
great ride builder that we have it onto
its studio and essentially you know
please you know try to use it it's it's
something we're working really hard on
to make your life easier so we released
constantly at one point to last year
with a bunch of capabilities we you know
you can set up your UI by you know
creating relations between elements
there's a lot of capabilities here
relative positioning center etc etc and
there is some helper objects like
guidelines to help you set up your
screen up so it's already a very full
set of features but a month ago remit is
constantly at 1.1 which I did a lot of
bug fixes performance improvements new
features new ways of expressing your
layout and I'm just going to alight one
that you actually see on the slide the
barrier which allows you to position an
element relative to a set of elements so
whatever the position and the dimension
of those element that that element on
the right is going to position correctly
so essentially we've constantly at one
point one we have a really flexible
layout something that should essentially
let you express any UI and you can just
add it to your project by using normal
you know gradual dependency we are now
shipping on maven so should be very easy
for you to use it in your build server
etc but I think a lot of you here are in
this room to hear me talk about
constantly at 2.0 so
we've constructed up to 2.0 we are
starting with constantly at one and
constantly at one is a great base as I
said it gives the entire flexibility
that you need to create your UI and it
comes with the UI builder and one of the
concepts that we introduced and
constantly at one was the concept of
helper object object that even though
you can manipulate them into the UI
builder in the UI builder did you not
appear on your screen when you run the
application but essentially they help
you create your UI so one of them is the
guideline object you know if your
designer
typically you know specify a UI with
horizontal lines etc well you can simply
replicate those in in your UI so it's a
lot easier for you to set up your screen
similarly with one point one we have the
barrier I just talked about and what's
nice with those helpers object is that
we do have some support for them in the
UI builder so you can simply manipulate
them and add elements to those helper
object in the component tree by dragging
elements into them something you might
not realize is that those helpers
objects are not view groups they only
keep a reference to the views so we
still keep the entire view tree very
flat but because they are just
references we can have you know one
object being referenced in multiple
helpers and that's starting to be very
interesting for us and you can think
about the helpers a way of keeping a few
reference to a bunch of views you can
still get a flat hockey and the way we
think about it is that a helper gives
you a way of you know encapsulating a
behavior in 2.0 we are going to expose
those helpers as the constraint at work
class so you'll be able to create your
handle on helpers and if you have your
own helpers in your project similar to
what we have with custom views they will
be present in the Android studio so
you'll be able to manipulate your own
objects
we we kind of highlighted three broad
categories for the helpers in 2.01
categories layout manipulation helpers
that are going to help you create a
layout
another one is helpers that will apply
something after the layout has been done
so kind of post layout and finally we
have some helpers because helpers are
views or can be views as well helpers
that we can use to do some specific
rendering specific display for the
virtual layout this is one of the
concepts that we are really keen on the
idea is that the helper is going to set
the constraint for you the simplest
example I can think of is a linear
helper you know if you created a chain
in constantly at one well that will
allow you to do exactly the same thing
but you will manipulate it a little bit
like linear layout for instance the only
difference is that you have all the
features that chain provide you and the
way you use them it's very easy it's a
normal view you can constrain that you
itself when the only thing you need to
care here is that list of ID's that you
reference we have another virtual layout
that will launch with 2.0 which
essentially implements the flexbox
layout semantics so those object are
pretty useful but you know at the same
time I think you know pretty expected
but when we are developing those helpers
we come up with you know additional use
cases so one example of post layout
object is a flying object let's say that
you want your objects on first layout to
fly in well you could simply reference
this object with the flying decorator
and that's all
so no code it's purely declarative you
just add that to your XML file reference
that object and it will animate on first
launch we have another object that's
very powerful
and layers allows you essentially a lot
of things it can it kind of allows you
to consider a set of views and apply
operation to them so there is a bunch of
graphical operation that you can apply
and we will do the math behind the scene
to apply them correctly you can also set
it up so that it takes by default the
bounds of the views that it references
and you can use it to set up a
background very easy diff and that way
another use case that we will expose is
you could use the layer a little bit
like you would use layers in graphical
photo editors to have a bunch of layers
to specify your elements and when you
are hockey okay with those elements
constraints you could lock that layer
and be sure to not inadvertently modify
them so it's a very powerful helper here
is a quick example on how it would look
like by drawing a background around a
bunch of buttons being reference and
without having to set up the constraint
manually I can you know easily see
around the subject with with a
background and just to prove you that we
are still with a flat view tree we can
apply this operation that I'm talking
about and everything will just follow
but the background will stay where it is
so it's a city example it's just to show
you the the potential of those objects
another use useful decorator is a
circular reveal and it actually does
what it says and it's the typical effect
that you've been familiar with with
material design and if I press the
button that's better the interesting
thing here is that you'll notice that it
only applies to the elements referenced
so we have this row of buttons that we
are not referenced and so the circular
reveal did not apply to them and if you
played with circular reveal you see that
it's actually a bit tricky to do that
the interesting thing here as well is
that we are not creating our own
circular reveal we are just using the
normal circular reveal but essentially
we package it in a way that makes it a
lot easier for you
to play with and using your layouts so
on that same idea we have decorators
that are helpers that are here to draw
things and same things we reproduce and
you can draw something with it so that's
probably a little confusing in terms of
what type of effect you can get with
that so let me show you so you may want
an effect like that now kind of a lava
lamp effect with you know those blows
moving around and what you'll see is
that the result of that effect will
depend on the position of those blobs
but the final rendering has to take in
account all of them and that would
normally be a very difficult affair to
achieve so the way it works with the
helpers that you can think about it that
way you have a converse right like what
you paint on you have actually some
image views that are essentially sitting
on top of that and they are normally
made views so you lose nothing here they
are normal views normal widgets you can
apply the usual things but we put their
own background to be transparent and
then we use the decorator to do the
background and you can easily get an
effect like that now for instance a
little slower there you go so
and just to show you the bonds are
correct we still have our images
another type of decorator that you can
use in your project is the bottom panel
decorator so let's say that you have a
layout like that
that you may have created by using a
chain very easy but you'd like to set a
background on those objects and maybe
change their colors so you can simply
apply this decorator or reference this
element and we'll do the rest of the
work and because well we can do a little
more interesting stuff here you know I
can show you what it may look like when
you click on those buttons so just to
give you an idea of the type of effects
you can get with decorators
so I'm clicking on this my menu comes in
I can press that so model menu comes in
I press it and there's a circular reveal
it's of course a very silly UI but it
just to give you you know an idea of
what you can do
what's very interesting here is that if
if you look at at it in studio and you
know if i zoom on the componentry you'll
notice that actually you know we mostly
have just views and just a bunch of
helpers there's actually no code here so
I think it's really it's really useful
addition to your tool set as a
programmer to try to really separate you
know the the feel with you know the
actual you know you know you actual that
data and your actual behavior in your
application so to summarize with your
helpers you know you can tag your views
with those essentially you can
encapsulate and reuse the behavior and
it's all declarative let me talk briefly
about the earth management so you've
been probably playing with constraint
set on the constantly at one point one
which is a way of encapsulating an
entire state for a layout and if you
switch between two of those states you
can animate them so that's very nice but
you know
initializing those things is a little
cumbersome you have to create your
layout I know lot of layout manually etc
so in 2.0 will have a separate XML file
that lets you specify States because
essentially that's what they are this is
you know I have a I have a layout that's
a lot has different representation
represent the different states and you
can associate that with with default
layouts so the way you would use them is
simply by calling set your description
and we'll do the rest of the job you can
then switch state simply by calling set
States with the state ID and that's it
one nice thing is that you can specify a
region on when a specific constraint
constraint set is going to be applied
and by plugging that into on
configuration changed
and I'm showing that on a chrome on the
Chromebook you'll see that automatically
depending on the size of the window
we'll switch layouts so that's a very
it's a very easy way for you to have
different behavior for layouts if you
want to little more fancy to be little
more fancy you can on the preview change
plug a transition manager and then we
will animate the layout transition so I
think we've devices that Chromebooks
that's the type of use case that's are
going to be more and more useful and
that's essentially layout management so
to quickly recap on cosmically r2 so far
we have the helpers API we have those
virtual layouts and decorators we have
the REST API we also have other stuff I
haven't talked about like a new fluent
API for manipulating the constraints
directly and we have motion layouts and
to talk about motion layouts I am really
happy to introduce John thanks
now I'm really excited to show you guys
motion layout it's a brand new layout
that we're introducing with constrained
layout 2.2 so let's kind of get into it
it starts off with a subclass of
constraint they are called motion layout
it's a layout it has all the properties
of constraint layout but the whole trick
with animating between two constraint
sets that's will be done for you by
motion layout so if you have two
constraint sets it will switch between
them and animate between them by itself
but you notice because it's a constraint
layout you can actually use the helpers
that were shown there but it also
provides you with the ability to edit
the custom attributes of the system so
you notice the blue light there it's
changing because it's a custom attribute
in the system so constraint sets now can
handle custom attributes allows you to
animate anything one of the other things
that it does is it allows you to control
on touch directly so it'll manage your
touch events by tracking your velocity
of your finger and matching it the
velocity of views in the system and
naturally give you a smooth transition
between them by a touch we also support
help us because it's just a constraint
layout so they help us Nicholas just
showed there the air too and they can
they can work together and apart now
let's change the transition a little bit
we want to move the eye into the middle
of the screen but if we look
mostly there's a bit of a problem here
you see the arrow
clashes with the I will have to fix that
and the way we do that is a feature we
call keyframes essentially if we have a
beginning and an end of a path we can
distort the path by adding a keyframe
and once we add the keyframe it will
avoid the path it's pretty cool so now
we have a motion scene it has constraint
sets it has on touch keyframes custom
attributes with a little flag on your
device you can see the path of all the
objects you've set in it so you can
understand what all your views are doing
on device so one of the nice things that
we've supported it is nesting of
constraint set of motion layouts so in
this particular example we have two
views being animated by a third view
they're both constraint motion layouts
and they are both being driven by a
third motion layout the top view is just
doing a fade to black
but you'll notice something else in that
view this is an animated view that was
custom written by Nicolas that is being
driven by motion layout because it's
implements a non progress method so you
couldn't drive your own custom
animations directly from motion layout
so one of the things that's really good
at is synchronizing motions it's
anything that's very complex sequences
of many things moving on the screen
it'll handle
and we'll also allow you to interact
with it with the touch so we added one
more thing to the system something we
call cycles this is the ability to build
into the keyframes oscillatory behaviors
it can vibrate and shake in various ways
and you might wonder okay so what did we
do with these key cycles so in this
particular example first let me just
unfold them with a staggered effect but
now I can take one and have it roll
because it's oscillating oh I can do a
different effect I can have it sort of
bounce along the edge I got bored and I
just had that one flying around another
typical example is you put it like doing
a little shake at the end so now one of
the cool things is we build that it is
so we're building an editor for that
thing we call it the motion editor it's
part of the design surface but now
you'll be able to do those edits
directly in the design surface so kind
of to take you through how you would do
that in the design surface this based on
constraints layout you just create your
constraints for your first constraint
set switch to the second edit the
constraints for the second constraint
set and then once you do that if you hit
play it will show you the animation
between those two constraint sets
there's a checkbox to enable showing you
the path so now you can see the path but
how would you add a keyframe
well you just position the cursor where
you want it you add the type of keyframe
that you want to add and you can just
distort the key
by selecting the keyframe and moving it
around on the screen and let's just do
that one more time so you could see it
just select a position any position
creates a keyframe and then we just move
it
so here's much more complex motions
they're all being animated this one has
quite a few keyframes in it just
designed to allow you to set
transparency on some things change the
size of other things move them around
but it all works in the IDE thank you
so one last thing you you probably are
here to try all those things so a lot of
that is actually 3.2 all the sample data
we showed you all the current
integration we've constantly at one
point one go
don't not three point you try it out we
release the canary 14 13 dis dis choose
there so please give it a try confront
Leah to the library
we've motion layout we are thinking
about releasing it in a few days
hopefully and motion editor it's an
ongoing work but we are really excited
about it
so think about it there is code labs for
the navigation editor as well for the
chrome resize API we showed you we also
want to hear from you in general we are
easily you know Richard all the four of
us but for this particular session they
speak back you can feel we are also
going to have an office hour this
afternoon after this session so please
come see us and that concludes a touch
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]